do you know what China's Ministry of
State security is making people do like
imagine in America you couldn't talk
about Co when the thing was high or
vaccine or this is how you get silenced
in China today if you talk badly about
their economy they're deplatforming you
and silencing you let me read you a
couple different things that's going on
in China they're freaking out from the
top so in June three Finance
commentators with 4.7 million wo
followers wo like their Twitter Facebook
and medium combined they were blocked by
the platform as a punishment for ready
hypen up the unemployment rate spreading
negative information and smearing the
development of the Securities Market the
waybo account from wo Finance issued an
instruction against posting any comments
that badmouth the economy and later they
deleted it so means they're worried
about it Bloomberg reported that several
online Finance influencers had been told
by wo to avoid Crossing red lines and to
post less about the economy waybo did
not reply to a request for comment
China's Ministry of states security
published an article on 12th of December
just a few weeks ago saying there was a
need to sing the bright theory of
China's economy and in a separate we
chat the same Ministry said various
cliches intended to denigrate China's
economy continue to appear their Essence
is to use false narratives to construct
a discourse trap and cognitive trap of
China's decline in order to cast doubt
on the system and path of socialism with
Chinese characteristics they're freaking
out for many different reasons we're
going to talk about that today so look
I've been in the financial industry
since 9/11 the day before 911 and I've
owned stocks bonds mutual funds real
estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Harford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so text award value to 65532
or call 86
6695 7074 or go to American hardford
gold.com so if you give value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel why is China
you are so big so proud why are you so
worried China what are you worried about
maybe it's because China turns negative
for the first time in 25 years in what
in quarterly foreign direct investment
inflows to China in billions of dollars
that is not a good chart when you look
at this because since they've been part
of the World Trade Organization there's
never been a year where people outside
of China were not putting money in it's
negative you know what negative is could
be the fact that they're taking money
out maybe millionaires are leaving China
you think that's really happening or
let's take a look according to
millionaire net migration of 20123 these
are the top five countries that are
expected to see the most number of
millionaires migrate in 2023 look at
who's at the top China
13,500 an increase of 10,800 in 202 too
then he got India that went lower which
means fewer people are leaving then he
got UK that doubled people are leaving
UK they don't feel safe then he got
Russia then he got Brazil but China is
losing millionaires imagine you're
living in China you're like all these
billionaires want to leave this place
they're having a hard time taking their
money out they're trying to do a lowkey
S I'm leaving for vacation but we're
never coming back why are you going on
vacation for 2 weeks 4 weeks 6 weeks 8
weeks 10 weeks 5 months 6 months one
year what's go are these guys going to
come back or not it's like billionaires
that left New York and went to Florida
they're not coming back to New York oh
they're going to come back no no they're
not coming back to New York these are
people that want to leave China let me
continue giving you more numbers here
the real estate sector in China is 30%
of their GDP 40% of China's home sales
since 2021 are linked to property
companies that have defaulted 40% home
sales have fallen 29% across major
cities property investment in the first
11 months of 2023 fell by
99.4% on year according to National
Bureau of Statistics you unemployment
imagine you're trying to get a job this
is what it looks like this is not good
it keeps increasing youth unemployment
in China from 16 to 24 every year has
gone up it's the highest right now
that's been in a long time
21.3% you got to get these people
working they can't get a job they have a
problem in China that is kind of you a
good problem but it's bad for the
government it's good for the people and
here's what the problem imagine like
total money supply we have in America
how much money you think it is it's
roughly $20 trillion we collectively
there's roughly 20 trillion right China
has $40 trillion okay so you look at the
2m2 supply you're like wait a minute
China's got twice as much as we do yes
but they have a problem what's the
problem China's people don't spend money
they're Savers household savings
continues to rise as Chinese consumer
remain cautious look at this 2021 2022
2023 they are not spending any money so
they're investing in real estate is the
only thing pretty much they're investing
in at the time give or take but the
consumers are saying I am not going to
be spending money in America we're like
hey buy not pay later credit card send
me more credit cards they're not doing
that in China China's trying to force
consumers to go buy stuff so we can make
the economy grow but it is not happening
they are not optimistic about what's
about to happen to China okay so I got
to take this kit to soccer but let me
give you my final thoughts before we
wrap up so here's the last part how do
you judge success by a company or a
sales organization or a sports team
championships sales money being made
China lost 45 billionaires from 22 to
2023 that's 7 a half% of their total
billionaires they lost in one year the
world decreased only by 2% and us
flatlined in a number of billionaires
but China lost 7.5% why are you losing
so many billionaires aren't you supposed
to be the place that produces the most
billionaires why are you decreasing
these are real numbers and this the kind
of data that China doesn't want their
people to see or talk about and that's
who they're silencing I wonder why
numbers don't look good and that
government when you live in a country
that it's a communistic country they can
silence you at times having said that if
you got value out of this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
I got two other videos for you to watch
with China one of them is China
comparing to India because they are very
much competing against each other if
you've not seen the numbers you watch
this and the other one is the China's
demographic the average age being 38
years old 39 years old it's not a good
look if you've not seen this this is a
very big problem they're concerned about
click you to watch that take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
n